visitez les plus grands monuments du
monde n'a géré entre les poissons de cet
aquarium tout en couleurs l'exposition
légaux fait voyager d'univers en univers
son travail qu'elle dure un peu plus
longtemps que le temps d'organiser de
visiter la salle de prévoir comment
organiser l'exposition trouver des
oeuvres pour les amener toutes ses
installations proviennent des
collections personnelles de sept membres
de l'association illinoise brésis des
passionnés de la brique en plastique
parmi eux maxime est fier d'exposer pour
la première fois ses lego star wars
un jour j'ai fait un exposé est prise
depuis je l'atteins depuis longtemps
après on prend du temps
allez construire
et on prend du plaisir à les contrer si
les différends durent à ma fenêtre une
poussée de créativité l'association a
prévu un espace de construction où
l'imagination et les talents
d'architecte déco s'exprime tu fais
d'abord des escaliers puis je fais le
tour d'abord ans après je commence à
faire avant de retrouver le monde réel
on n'oublie pas de chercher les
personnages incongrus glisser dans ce
monument égyptiens nous ne révélerons
pas notre secret mais nous en avons déjà
trouvé quelques uns